[Music]
thank you so here's a little issue we
have in America today there are
currently about 250,000 people a year
who are dying in our hospitals due to
due to preventable deaths and I'm not
talking about negligence I'm talking
about little accidents right I'm talking
about the doctor in the morning not
properly briefing the doctor for the
evening you know I'm talking about
things that you know we can't sue
anybody there's nothing there's nothing
that we can see that's wrong but there's
250,000 preventable deaths every year
that's about 20 747s going down every
single week that's what's the equivalent
to and the confusing thing is that we
have the best doctors in the world we
have the most advanced technology in the
world some of the medical equipment we
have is the best in the world the
medicines we have are the best in the
world so you start asking yourselves why
are these things happening and the
reason is not because of any of those
things the reasons are actually
something vastly more simple and
something very very human five percent
of hospital administrators are doctors
most of them are number crunchers
hospitals are run like businesses
hospitals are run by the numbers and the
problem isn't the people who are giving
the care they're very highly trained the
problem is the way those people are
cared for because what we've done is
we've created cultures and hospitals
where the people who are doing the
caring aren't cared for and so all of
these little preventable deaths are
happening because they don't feel like
they're a part of anything they're just
doing their jobs and they don't get
along that well and there's not a lot of
camaraderie and the impact is death
right now I use this example because
it's exaggerated because the impact is
so powerful but the problem is the same
in our own companies right which is we
come to work and we're told you must
care for your clients you must care for
your customers you must make them the
focus of
you do and yet why aren't the people who
are managing us from the top caring
about us so yes in a hospital the impact
is worse but the impact that we're
having on the outside world is just as
bad in other words we're not working at
our best we don't care for the things
we're doing we're not helping each other
is the most important part and the
residual impact is that we are
unfulfilled by the work that we do and
when we run fulfilled by the work that
we do we focus on the details and when
we focus on the details we retract from
each other when we track from each other
we feel lonely and when we feel lonely
cancer goes up heart disease goes up
diabetes goes up in other words by going
to work we're killing ourselves
literally there's another study that was
released not that long ago that says
that parents who work late the negative
impact that it has on their children is
little to none they may feel guilty as
parents but the negative impact that it
has on the raising of their children is
little to none however parents who come
home from jobs they hate or don't love
their kids are more likely to be bullies
at school and now you think about the
bullying epidemic we have in America
right where there's this disturbing
number of young children who are killing
themselves suicides because of bullies
the problem is not the schools and the
problem isn't even the parenting the
problem is the jobs the parents have
this is the importance and this is the
power of the work that we do in the
places we go to work right most of us
mean like we listen to the the the
unemployment statistics they say you
know we're all-time high record high
nine to ten percent unemployment right
and people go Mike oh that's terrible
and I hear that number and I go well
that means ninety-one percent still have
a job right now granted we want to get
that employment number up but that means
ninety-one percent is still going to
work the question is how many of them
are coming home fulfilled by the work
that they do and how many of them are
waking up inspired to go back to work
the next day if we don't love our works
we don't look out for each other if we
don't look out for each other we feel
lonely if we don't feel lonely all these
negative things happen so what example
can I share with a creative audience
about how to change this the United
States Marine Corps
I had the great honor last week of
spending a week with the Marines I spent
a couple days at Camp Lejeune and then I
went for a few days to Parris Island to
watch them go through boot camp and this
isn't a room it's a remarkable
remarkable human experiment that they're
doing and even though they know what
works they don't know why it works but
they don't need to know why because they
know that it works right but what's
happening is they're taking a group of
strangers people who don't know each
other who were showing up and within a
very very short period of time learned
to trust each other so much that they
would give their lives for each other
right and we know everyone sort of
anyone who's ever worn a human reformed
knows that no one runs into battle for
God and country it doesn't happen it's
for the guy to the left of me and the
guy to the right of me that's the reason
they do what they do right and these
sort of remarkable stories of heroism
where people rush into very very
dangerous situations to save others and
they always ask the question why did you
do it why would you risk your life why
would you put yourself at risk for them
and the answer is always the same
because they would do it for me in other
words what gives them the confidence to
put themselves at great risk is the
knowledge that someone would do the same
for them we would put ourselves a great
risk for our companies if we knew that
our companies would put themselves a
great risk for us but they don't so we
don't now one of the things that's
remarkable about the Marines and if you
go read and you know this is the most I
asked these young and they're 21 22
years old some of these of these lance
corporals the grunts you know the guys
the infantry I mean this is the lowest
of the low the ones we actually send in
to battle the frontlines and I asked
them are you misunderstood in America
and they said yes unanimously they all
nodded I said what what do people think
of you and one stood up and says they
think we're baby killers I said how does
it feel he says it hurts
and when I say we'll tell me a story
then that captures to you what it means
to be a Marine the feeling you have of
being a Marine
tell me a story that captures it and I
expected to hear stories of I took a hit
and somebody saved me or I ran into a
firefight and pulled something I
expected these stories of heroism not a
single story like that came out
those stories exist but those aren't
that tall the stories they told me that
capture what it means to be a marine one
of the stories they told me was a young
boy in Afghanistan who would come around
every morning and sell kebabs to the
Marines and then one day he showed up
and he was all beaten up and he didn't
go to his parents for help and he didn't
go to his friends to help he came to the
Marines for help because he trusted them
more than anyone else they told me a
story that captured how they feel of a
sevilla JH that had been overrun by the
taliban and the residents of the village
could couldn't go home because they
would be killed by the Taliban and so
they were just living by the river the
problem was winter was coming and one of
the the elders came to the Marines
knocked on the door and said I need you
to come down to the river and kill us
and the Marine said what are you talking
about he says if we go back home we'll
be killed by the Taliban and if we stay
out there we're gonna die slow deaths
this winter it's easier if you just come
and kill us please the Marines overran
the Taliban village pushed the Taliban
out a year later they went back to this
village and people were playing
volleyball these were the stories they
told me that capture what it means to be
a Marine they believed in doing good for
others and the fulfillment they get when
they put themselves at risk so that
others may prevail is overwhelming this
is not unique to the Marine Corps this
is all human beings the feeling of
fulfillment comes from doing something
for another the feeling from fulfillment
comes from the exertion of time and
energy for someone else if you are
walking to work and you throw a few
pennies in a cup and you come to work
and you say to your friends hey guys I
gave a dollar to somebody homeless this
morning what are you friends get it to
say yeah good right I gave 20 bucks to
somebody homeless they'd be like yeah
good for you right what have you come in
in the morning you say hey I gave up my
Saturday and I went and paid missus
painted a school in the inner city
people go whoa cool wow cool and all of
a sudden not only are they inspired to
do something good themselves but the
feeling that that you have persists the
amazing thing is that when we do good
for others that actually inspire
others to do good for others this is
provided for us prymatt illogically
anthropologically it's a all part of the
survival of the species you know sex
feels good so that will do it so we can
procreate and perpetuate the species but
we're social animals and so we have to
provide for the fact that we'll maintain
strong bonds and build cultures right
because that's what humans do we're
cultural animals and so when we do good
for others and we look out for those in
our tribe we look out for those in our
group it actually feels good
biologically releases oxytocin this
chemical that's released when you do
good for others is released and it makes
you feel good the amazing thing is the
more oxytocin and you have in your body
the more you want to do good for others
the problem is we've replaced this
feeling the exertion of time and energy
with digital communications we've
replaced it with headphones we've
replaced it with money right think about
the invention of money right it used to
be money you know used to be like you go
to someone's house you cook them dinner
and the deal was they'll do the dishes
time and energy exchange for time and
energy and someone said I'll give you an
IOU right someone says I don't feel like
doing the dishes so I'm gonna give you
an IOU that I promise to do them another
day right and that's what money is it is
the promise for future goods or services
the promise of future goods and services
in other words we've replaced our own
time and energy with promises for
someone else to do it another day right
in other words there's no exertion of
time and energy and so the feeling
people get is that I did something for
you and you did nothing for me
you replaced it with a piece of paper
with an eye are you with a promise for
future goods and services the way we
find fulfillment is by doing good for
others so how did the marine zoo how do
you get people to do good for others we
all know this intellectually we know
that it's good to do good for others but
why don't we do it then why don't we do
it and what the Marines learned is
something that I completely did not
expect they can't just yell at these
guys to help each other that's not what
happens there's a few things that they
have to do first so we all heard of the
obstacle course right the Marines have a
thing called the obstacle course and
this is where they they build an aerobic
strength and Arabic strength muscle
strength and it's timed and all of this
good stuff they have another course
called the confidence course and it's
never timed and most of the obstacles on
this course cannot be completed by
yourself
they must be completed in teams you have
no choice that's just how it's designed
and what they say is the first two weeks
of boot camp everybody's there to outdo
each other and prove that they're strong
just kind of like when we start in a job
would prove we want to show how great we
are we'll work a little harder we'll do
good work look how good my design is
right it's all about us and how good we
are right but they keep putting them in
situations where they can't do things by
themselves and what starts to happen
very slowly they said after about two
weeks they start cheering for each other
now they get in trouble when they do but
they start cheering for each other and
then before too long you see them
organically start helping each other and
what happens is if there's one person
who's weak and refuses to help each
other the others or even if there's one
person who's strong who's you know I was
the star college athlete and they get to
every the end of every office to call me
just stand there and wait for everybody
to finish and they don't help each other
what starts to happen as organically the
group starts to ostracize that person
organically they get ostracized until
they learn that the only way that they
will get through this thing the only way
they will survive boot camp is if they
ask for help because they have no option
the problem is no one will help them
until they're willing to help another
it's the deal we have to make it's
called vulnerability and risk we have to
take the risk
to make ourselves vulnerable yes you
might do something for someone else and
they may not do something back for you
that's the risk you run that's the risk
you run it's not about it's not about
giving everything to them and and sort
of huge big overwhelming risk it's about
little things and little things it's
like going on a date right it's like if
I went on a date with somebody I came
home and I said after one date I said
I'm marrying her baby like what are you
nuts
I'd be like I'm in love they're like but
you're you this is crazy I'm like I know
I'm in love
she feels the same way and we both know
it's nuts right now you know that you're
gonna be like go on a couple more dates
right we know instinctively that the
strong bond that's create that that
needs to be created first takes more
than a week right we know that right but
if I've been dating somebody for seven
years and we haven't you know married
you'll be like dude what is wrong right
in other words we know that it takes
more than seven days and we know that it
takes less than seven years the problem
is we don't know how long it takes
somewhere in the middle all human buns
are the same like when you show up at
work when you show for the first time
when you're new don't expect that people
will look out for you and they won't
expect you to look out for them in seven
days
it won't happen but if you've been
working at a job for a few years and you
don't have the undone teeth at the sort
of the the absolute confidence that if
you turn your back you will not get
stabbed you can rely on somebody you can
give them something nothing will go
wrong
you will share the credit no one will
throw you under the bus if you don't
have that in a few years something's
wrong something's wrong I don't know how
long it takes but I know that's more
than a week and I know it's less than
seven years and the Marines
fundamentally understand that before
anyone is willing to put themselves out
for another they have to have
self-confidence real self confidence you
have to be confident in yourself and
your own ability before you're willing
to help another if you're insecure at
all about your own ability it's an oxy
it's sort of a paradox right how am I
can I overcome my confidence
you know my self-confidence and we all
have ego issues at all times you know we
all do right but if I'm not confident
myself I won't help another it's a
paradox because then we need someone to
look out for us before we're willing to
help our peers right this is what
management is supposed to do the drill
instructors the school they are there
our parents
they are there for one reason and one
reason only to help us feel strong and
good about ourselves but look at the way
we talk to each other little bit look a
budgets been cut and so what do you get
told I need you guys to do more with
less right that's what we're told hey
guys I need you guys to do more with
less that's we're told by our clients by
our bosses by our parents this is what
we're told right that's like your
parents telling you when you're young I
no you're stupid figure it out right
you're not as smart as the other kids
what do you want me to do right it's the
exact same thing I need you to do more
with less right what we need to be
telling people is I need you I need you
to do more with what you have right you
have capacity you have strength you have
talent you have kapap ability I need you
to do more with what you have we don't
celebrate what we've got we criticize
for what we don't have this is the
responsibility of management to take us
under their wing and help us understand
our own value to ourselves
close your eyes and think back to high
school and think of that one teacher who
took you under their wing and cared for
you and looked after you and helped you
realize that you are capable of more
than you thought you were and you and
you you probably are the person you are
today in some part because of that
person right do you have that name
what's the name tell me the name tell me
the name of the teacher okay give me the
name okay I can point to anybody and you
can tell me that name now tell me the
names of all the other teachers you had
that day can't remember them can you
this is the power of those who teaches
confidence we will literally carry their
names around with us for the rest of our
lives wouldn't you want to be that
person wouldn't you want to be the
person that twenty years from now 30
years from now 40 years from now I can
do this exercise with somebody and they
will tell me your name this is the power
of helping others realize their own
strengths this is what management and
leadership is supposed to be doing
they're supposed to be caring for us and
helping us realize our own value and by
the way if you have anybody who reports
to your works for you your
responsibility is not to make them meet
the deadline your responsibility is not
to make sure that they do as you say
your responsibility is to make sure that
they understand their own strengths
their own value and that they are way
way more talented than they think they
are and the only way they will learn
that
is if you put them in situations in
which they can fail and you hold them
and you support them and you give them
talent and you give them skills and you
give them education and you watch their
backs and if they fall over you
encourage them to get back up and if
they follow the you carriage them to get
back up and if they fall over you
encourage them to get back up until they
figure it out themselves
it's called confidence it's your
responsibility to help others find it
into others responsibility to help you
find yours and the amazing thing is as
soon as you start feeling confident in
your own ability you naturally help each
other that's what happens it's called
trust in the military they give medals
to people who are willing to sacrifice
themselves so that others may gain in
business we are willing to give bonuses
to people who will sacrifice others so
that we may gain we have it backwards
and then we complain about how we don't
love our jobs and we complain about how
the work is suffering and we complain
about how budgets are being cut and we
can complain and complain and complain
and the first thing we do is blame each
other and become more selfish and
worried about my pay and my benefits in
my this and this is what happens when we
are unfulfilled we look at the metrics
and we say they're not good enough when
we are fulfilled we don't care about the
metrics this is why when you have a job
you love and you get a call that says
I'll offer you tons more money and great
benefits you like I'm not interested I'm
not interested I I'm not interested I'm
very happy here but we'll give you more
that's not the reason I'm here I'm here
because I love it I'm here because I
care for the people I work with and I'm
here because the people I work with care
for me this is the world I imagine this
is the world I imagine and here's the
great thing if you take little risks I'm
not talking about big things little
things if you start doing little things
for each other
the amazing anthropological response is
other people will start doing little
things for others - I was walking down
the street two days ago and a guy's
backpack was open and a whole bunch of
paper fell out as he was walking down
the street and I happened to be behind
him and so my friend and I just sort of
we were in mid conversation and in mid
conversation we never even stopped
talking
we just bent down as would have helped
him gather his papers and them back to
him sort of pointed out that his bet
book bag was his you knows back
zipped and he said thanks and we walked
out it was like no big deal right we get
to the end of the the street we stand at
that we're waiting it to cross the
street we still talking we haven't
stopped talking and the guy in front of
us turns to us and says I saw you help
that guy that was really cool but here's
what's great about that the guy will go
do something for someone else simply
because he saw us bend down and pick up
paper for someone else he will actually
go do something for someone else because
of it right he he won't give to charity
because he sees me put a dollar in a cup
but he will actually help someone
because he saw someone also helps
someone little things hold a door open
for someone say thank you to the person
hold the door open for you smile to the
barista little little things you know
put your foot in the subway when the
door is closing so someone who's running
will make it hit the open at the
elevator don't go or pretend you didn't
see that's the best one you know if I
saw sorry all right do it a little time
and a little energy and you'll find
around work that people give a little
time and a little energy back to you and
you'll give a little more time and a
little more energy you go for a coffee
with someone then you go for a two hour
coffee and you go for a coffee and a
lunch then you go for a lunch and a
dinner then you go for a dinner in a
movie and then you sleep over and then
you sleep over two nights and then you
go on holiday together and eventually
you get married right it's slow it takes
time and we can't rush it you know if
when we rush it it's all fake do things
for others and watch watch how much
others do for you but you know go you go
get yourself a cup of coffee from the
coffee chute machine in the morning make
one for someone else it takes a little
extra time it takes a little extra
energy that's the point that's the point
and here's the best part
you will feel so good at the end of the
day so good thank you very much
thank you next month is Bre Pettis who
is one of the founders of MakerBot he's
gonna be speaking seriously excited and
the funny thing is I ran into him about
four weeks ago in a playground and I saw
him sitting there I've never met him but
I recognized him from videos that I've
watched about MakerBot and I like while
I'm chasing my kid is like can I go up
to him this is weird it's a stall key
can I do it is so I eventually I just
pulled everything together went up it
was like you're to make a buck guy right
he goes yup and his wife looks at me
you're a Swiss Miss I recognize your
kids from Instagram so and and the next
thing you know he's speaking next month
how awesome is this and then for those
of you who've been here in November at
11-11-11 who has been at the rainbow
birthday parade well you should partake
next Saturday because jesse has another
rainbow birthday parade and she's
actually trying to break a world record
and having the longest rainbow birthday
parade ever that watches over the
Brooklyn Bridge and there's a ginormous
marching bang gonna be here and Chris
who's our audio/video guy he's actually
in that band it's called them now I'm
blanking on it the hungry March Bend yes
I can't believe I've got just blanked on
it so if you want to predict in this you
should it's so much fun you need to
dress in one color we're going to line
up monochromatic Lee rainbow style and
March so and you have to sign up at the
largest rainbow parade that
eventbrite.com please come it's
super-fun bring your kids if you have
kids that's it see you next month I hope
thank you for coming out and thank you
again Simon
you